the Netflix horror mystery show stranger
things has been praised for its
pitch-perfect omage to the 1980s and
that includes its great opening credits
sequence it plays for almost a full
minute before every episode but it looks
so good I never skipped over it
watching it made me wonder what does it
take to make something like this so I
called up Michelle Daugherty
she's a creative director at imaginary
forces the studio that made the title
sequence you want it to feel original
you want it to feel like that title
sequence couldn't work in front of
another show you may not have heard of
Imaginary Forces but you've probably
seen their work they're responsible for
the opening credits to Mad Men Boardwalk
Empire Chuck the Pacific Jessica Jones
Late Night with Seth Meyers
I can go on it's a long list when they
first got on the phone with stranger
things show winners Matt and Ross
tougher they knew they wanted to go for
a style similar to what the studio our
greenberg associates did in the 70s and
80s with alien the dead zone and altered
states the duffer's had sent us these
paperback books probably ones that they
read as kids right and so we looked at
the typography on those and you know
they range right but they're all kind of
in the same vein of popular typefaces of
the 80s she sent me their early drafts
of the title sequence and you can
clearly see the influence of those book
covers the duffer brothers picked this
one which eventually became this let's
talk about the typeface it's called ITC
Ben gat and it was made in 1978 by a
jazz percussionist turned designer named
Edie Ben get here it is on the choose
your own adventure book series from the
80s and 90s and on the Smiths 1987 album
Strangeways here we come it's also been
the font of Paramount's FBI piracy
warning since 1995 I often think of the
sequences really a celebration of that
typeface in a way too because you really
get to see the most beautiful parts of
it in the old days before animation
software title sequences were shot
optically which is just another way of
saying that they were made manually
frame by frame
with a projector and a camera for
stranger things the title designers
wanted to replicate that gritty look
they wanted to make it look like they
were imperfections in the image so to do
that they read up these things they call
them Kota lists that's basically an old
film format that produces a really high
contrast image and they filmed what it
looks like when light shined through
those film letters
we reference some of those
inconsistencies those like what you call
mistakes we wanted it to have this
tactile feel and we want it to be
organic and of the time period they then
use those physical references to animate
the titles digitally that's why you see
subtle flickering and shaking in the
text the end result is an eerie mix of
digital and physical mediums and with
this great tract from the cement
survived it sets the tone for one of the
summer's biggest TV hits
you